[Applause]
i really want to build a bridge between
tv
broadcast and digital because it's how
we're all consuming
our viewing now so to see a special
treat that adam sandler and i did
together
go to our show website but not now hang
on one more second
trust we still have something to do it's
called the big goodbye
all right all right during the
commercial break
our virtual friends put on some yellow
sweatshirts that we sent them
okay hey guys and your yellow
sweatshirts oh
look at everybody oh
this is like oh like a yearbook that's
how this feels this is emotional
all right well we have a surprise for
one of you take a look up your sleeve
and there's a heart
on one of them literally
you guys looking all right tara lynn
taniko
it's you it's you
and your co-workers at sunshine
children's home
told us that you are a ray of light and
you make everyone happy
every single day especially the kids you
work with
who we hear love you so much oh tanika
tell me about what brings you
the most joy at your most important job
that you do
thank you um i i have to say that
um although we service a lot of children
who are on palliative or end of life
care
it's it's seeing those other kids go
home
it's it's knowing that we've provided
them the proper rehab services
um and and just
you know seeing the excitement in the
family's faces
and the excitement in the children's
faces when they get to go home
that's the most rewarding and joyful
part of my job
i think that what you do is so
incredibly altruistic and meaningful
and i am in awe of you as a human being
and we also heard that you were you know
like had some car situations so
uh we caught we just thought like god
getting to work should be the easiest
part of your day so
we called our friends at um hyundai
and um we're gonna give you a brand new
car 2021
hyundai limited edition are you
eating me yes you should never have to
worry about this with what you do
thank you for all that you do thank you
for inviting me into your homes today
i'm honored to be there and we will
hopefully
see you tomorrow and ongoing
thank you
[Music]
you